thank you matt thank you shutterstock
thank you all for being here
i'm going to go through a
no js running linux running robot
with you in five minutes and i have
about three minutes afterwards so i'm
gonna blaze through some slides so
let's go three minutes afterwards for q
a so if i miss anything
just shoot your hand up and i'll try to
answer anything that i can
in the allotted time as matt said my
name is ray hightower i run a software
company in chicago called wisdom group
we run a couple of conferences
one is windy city rails the other is
ruby curry in the
caribbean enough about me what is a
robot
a lot of times when someone thinks about
a robot or they talk about a robot we
might envision something with arms and
legs and a head or whatever
but we're a very technical audience and
we know that a robot typically you will
design it for the job that you want it
to do
it doesn't have to look like a human for
example
in the oil industry they use these
devices these are remotely operated
vehicles or
rovs to perform maintenance on
the uh the off sea drilling rigs that
they use
this happens to be a very huge robot if
you look in the lower left corner of the
photo
you'll see a person there doing
maintenance just so you can have an idea
of what
what kind of an rob that is and how
large it is
here's another rob about the same size
about the same cost range
and rovs for years for decades have cost
millions of dollars and they required a
great deal of expertise
and they were very big and they were
very heavy so
some guys got together and founded a
company called open rov two guys in
berkeley california the name of the
company is open rov
and their mission is to democratize
undersea exploration to make it
available to everybody
just as mainframe computers were once
millions of dollars
and eventually we had pcs and now now
tablets and smartphones that are only
100 a couple hundred dollars
this brings the rov down to the masses
so you get really excited about your
underwater robot
instead of it costing millions of
dollars you have something that costs
under a thousand dollars an open rob is
like 850 bucks
and you get really excited about it and
you send away for it or you pay for it
on the internet and this is what you get
a whole bunch of carts it's a kit
just like in the early days of pcs some
of you may remember the first map
you had to put it together and that's
what you have to do with the open rov
and here's mine in the process of me
putting it together
it took me a couple of weeks had to have
the solder
i had to learn acrylic welding had to
learn some other techniques that i was
not familiar with before
you know i'm a software developer i
learned to solder an electronic shop in
high school but that was a long time ago
and if you take a look i have my opener
over here the soldering connections are
not that great they're
good enough to make it work but that's
the work you have to do here's the
finished unit you know again on my
workshop with all my other junk
and in the back you can see the screen
now what's exciting about the rob
is that on board there's a beaglebone
black running linux
and running no js and when you are
controlling it you control it through a
web browser
what you see in front of you is a google
chrome
web browser running on ubuntu that's my
thumbs up in front of the camera that's
on the open rov unit
and notice the heads-up display isn't
that cool it's like flying a fighter
fighter plane under under uh underwater
uh here's another shot this was from my
first
expedition in lake michigan so i was
just giving it the thumbs up to make
sure that the camera was working
to the left and right you see the
batteries and if any of you want to see
the actual unit i have it here so you
can take a closer look at it
and if you want to ssh into the
beaglebone black that's on the unit
uh you can do that too i'll even give
you the password
uh so here's this is underwater here's
uh
these are rocks at the bottom of lake
michigan
and uh there are more rocks in the
bottom in lake michigan now i really did
see a fish when i was down there
but i did i didn't get a photograph of
that but
you know it's cool and uh our plan is to
do some other expeditions in some places
where the water is clear
you know we're going to do one in the
caribbean and jan in january a couple in
the caribbean in january
so let's talk about what's inside this
thing there's a beaglebone black about
the size of a raspberry pi
it runs linux in this case we're running
the ubuntu distribution of linux
that's the one that the open rfp team
put on there now why am i at a node
js meeting talking about this because it
runs node
and it runs socket io and it runs
tcpip and what's so cool is that
one of the examples that the owners of
the company use when they talk about
this they say that
you can have a an open rov
unit in barbados and control it from a
laptop
in taiwan because it talks tcp
over the internet how cool is that and
there are things we're going to be able
to do with this technology that we
haven't even thought of yet you know so
far
we're playing with this this is this is
a very new unit to me i started
experimenting with this just a few
months ago so it's very new
here's the technology stack you can't
see all of that it's
writing's too small so i simplified it
and i'll just go through this with you
real quick
we have three event loops we have an
event loop going on in the browser
chrome the open rov happens to work
better with chrome than any other
browser i think it's because it's uh
it's got the v8 javascript
engine there's an event loop on the
bingo bone black
where node.js is running and an event
loop on the arduino that's right there's
a beaverbone black
and an arduino inside of the unit i can
show you those if you want to come up
and take a look at it
sakuraio manages communications between
the browser
and the vegamon black on the unit and
there's a serial interface between the
arduino and
the beaglebone black and here are a few
more pictures
underwater being controlled and with a
scuba diver
and with a scuba diver again finally
what's ultra cool about open rov is that
it is completely
open source so if you go to github.com
open rob your node.js developers my
goodness you can contribute to this if
you want
you can do whatever you want with the
software you know that's what pull
requests are for right
so you know get full and you know knock
yourselves out
in this case i was visiting the factory
in berkeley
and on the left is an electrical
engineer 30 years of electrical
engineering experience on the right
is a pilot who pilots human sized
underwater vehicles and they're
collaborating on the next user interface
for openrov
and these two are customers they're not
part of the company so customers are
hanging out there
it's all open source it's very cool so
check it out at openrov.com
or if you want to know more about me i'm
at ray hightower.com
thank you for listening
are there any questions
yes sir so i'm guessing your tether
that's how the that's how you're
communicating
remotely yes the question was that
is there a tether and is the tether the
way that we communicate with the device
remotely
yes uh we have to use the tether because
we haven't figured out how to send
wi-fi underwater yet there are some
people who are working
on a way to convert tcp
to sound waves and let those go to a
device that
receives the sound waves and converts
that back into tcp
but who knows how far that that would be
cool isn't it it sounds really cool
yeah but i i haven't seen that breaking
successful yet but i've heard that there
are some people working on that
yes man how is how easy is it to get
started
you know that's that's really relative
i'm not very good with solder i can do
it okay and i was able to to knock it
out it took me about two weeks of nights
and weekends to knock this out
founder of the company can build one of
these in a day but you know he's better
right
uh so it really depends on what your
skill level is with soldering with
working with acrylic with working with
electronics
i had some experience in those other
areas but acrylic this was a brand new
acrylic experience for me so yeah
different uh different pace
for different people yeah
that's it yes sir uh in terms of battery
technology does this kit come with like
a charger
with the batteries oh yeah question
about batteries does it come with a
charger
uh what you do the kit does not come
with a charger but i bought and i'll
show you the charger up here if you want
to take a look at them
uh the batteries i bought those through
amazon grills do you buy anything right
the batteries are lithium-ion batteries
there are six of them they are about the
diameter
of a c battery a little bit longer than
a d but about the diameter of a c
and you'll see them inside the unit and
you do charge them they're lithium-ion
batteries and there's special charges
for those but they're readily available
from amazon.com
yes why'd you meet the arduino when
you got the beagleboard oh that's the
question why do you need the arduino
when you
got the beagleboard that's something
that i'm still learning about but here's
what i know so far
the arduino is doing things like
monitoring the depth sensor
and the direction sensor and it's
controlling the motors
it's the arduino is more of a
microcontroller and what the beaglebone
is doing is communicating with the
surface the bigger bone
most of its cpu cycles are are running
that node.js
app so you can see the images that are
getting sent up by the camera
and so that you can see the data that's
on the heads-up display
so really it's like delegation
responsibility yeah
yes
uh he's asking if i'm a gadget freak
how did i get involved with rob's uh
it was just it just looked cool
it just looks cool i i want to give you
some now
it looked cool and there was also a
legitimate reason right like there are
two reasons that all of us do some
do anything right there's a real reason
and there's a reason that we tell
everybody
um you know mike
my company my team and i we do ruby
development we do rails development
objective c
and uh i like the idea of learning other
technologies other languages i always
wanted to learn something about node
and this was a very good way to make
sure that i learned no
that's the reason i tell everybody
oh it's cool it's a full device yeah
yes what's the latency like between
getting images back from the camera and
sending commands for motors and such
oh yeah what what is the latency like
between uh getting the images back from
the camera and sending commands to the
motor
it's it is uh quick it's not so quick
that you would
um think it's instantaneous but uh if
for example you put it up on your desk
you wave your hand in front of it you
can see a delay between the waving of
your hand
and the image you see on your laptop so
i would say it's less than a second but
it's not so quick that humans can't
perceive it
i've never measured it though but you
can see it
yes
yes what's the maximum depth that it can
uh descend to
the maximum depth depends on how well
you assemble the unit
it is designed um it's waterproof and
actually
you know i was so surprised and happy
and ecstatic when i put it in lake
michigan and it didn't flood right
um it's designed to go down as low as
200 meters
depending on how well you assembled it
and because it's open source i've seen
in the open rov forum if you go to
openrov.com there's a forum there where
people discuss their experiences
there are some people who are working on
variations of the design whereby they
can go deeper than that
but if you go to 200 meters and a little
bit further than that it's going to
implode
and they have done actual destructive
testing to see
to see what happens when it can close
what happens is that the
electronics chassis the cylinder i can
show this to you we'll go back to one of
the photos
the cylinder that you see that holds all
of the electronics
it can take only so much pressure and in
about 200 meters
it's just had enough and it implodes and
that's all
yeah am i doing all right on time magnum
okay yes i'm sorry
you know what i would suggest for the
architecture that chart
uh two ways that you can get that one i
will post my slides at raytower.com
they'll be there uh by tomorrow evening
and the other thing is
if you go to github.com open rv
that architecture chart is there and the
cool thing is because this is open
source if you look at the repo you will
see updates that are as recent as a few
hours ago
so you may actually get something that's
more up-to-date than what i have in my
slides
yes
uh the question is do you need scuba
divers to watch the unit while it's down
there
it depends on how you want to do it and
the reason i say it depends is because
there are some people whom i've heard
want to use this unit
in places where they don't want to risk
human life
for example um i don't know uh
under the ice in the arctic somewhere
you don't want to risk human life down
there listen to somebody you don't like
go down there
that's not funny but uh
so it depends on how you want to do it
but ideally
you want to be able to send it down and
pilot it
while it's down there remotely that's
the idea oh and the other thing
more along the lines remote but some of
the uh some other
open rovers have done is they have like
in tahoe there was an exhibition in lake
tahoe
where they had the open rv and the
patrol unit on a boat
and then they had a huge wi-fi antenna
between the boat and a cabin on shore
and the actual pilot was in the cabin on
shore
it's tcpip it's tcp
and we know how to do that we know how
to do that all day yeah
everybody in this room knows how to do
that yes
yeah you know the question is the unit
modular and what's the clarity of
whatever depth you go down
i'm glad you asked that one of the
expeditions we did in lake michigan we
went in there with
very and i don't even have pictures of
that one uh it was a
stormy day i mean not raining but
the waves were kicking up all the silts
and we saw
nothing down below now the unit itself
has
two sets of bright white leds on the
front
so if it's just a matter of darkness you
can see things
and it also has on the front two lasers
that are 10 centimeters apart and
parallel to each other and they're not
designed for warfare
but the lasers are designed to measure
things they're 10 minutes
10 centimeters apart which is about that
far apart and they're parallel to each
other
so if you see an object and you want to
know how big it is you shine the two
parallel lasers on that object
and then you can get a rough idea of how
large the object is
yes
yeah the question is could you install
an infrared camera
yes you could if you wanted to it's all
open source so
especially if um you know i'm just
brainstorming this if you know of an
infrared camera
that has a usb interface the beaglebone
black inside of the device has a usb
interface
so if you happen to have an infrared
camera on you we can try that today
that would be cool
okay thank you very much